io sono un maker sono maker e si è messo
a fare l'imprenditore pur di far ricerca
e quindi trovare finanze per far ricerca
quest'anno jetta la quale sono molto
affezionato con hanno dato i ragazzi che
stanno su con le stampanti 3d quelli del
fab lab c'è scritto su tutti o per il
consorso degli altri
siamo quelli che genovesi a stampare se
non avessi a stampare l'arca dopo
l'alluvione che faccio io ritorno dalla
repubblica dominicana dove ero team
leader per un progetto di tv on demand o
per tutti i clienti a documenti italiani
avendo vissuto lì
e allora finiscono in un call center
quindi molto tempo per ragionare sul da
farsi in quel periodo
mia moglie faceva cartoni animati
produceva effetti speciali vedi qualcosa
di legato ai bit in 3d e mi veniva in
mente quello che diceva il lancer fed
che a capo del dipartimento di bit e
atomi al mit ovvero è possibile unire
con una tecnologia low cost oramai i
birrai atomi ovvero con le 3d printer
perfetto capisco cosa devo fare nella
vita
prendo la macchia inizia a girare tutta
l'italia per trovare un kit di stampante
3d e un kit di quindi che va in
audizione e un kit di una fresa che va
in sottrazione ma sempre 3d
volevo dire i bit tagliato o iniziato
nel 2012 da allora questa del primo kit
da allora ho continuato a costruire cnc
macchina a controllo numerico
apro un temporary store nel centro
storico della città è stato il primo 3d
store in italia dove uno poteva andare a
stampare qualsiasi cosa in 3d però a
farmi crescere è stata una critica come
succede normalmente pasticcere temporary
store vicino ma tu la famiglia c'è l'asp
amico le stampanti 3d vico che
nonostante adesso lui sia un cliente è
l'unico al quale non faccio lo sconto
qualsiasi cosa gli stampi come cake
topper lui a dover pagare a tutto per
cento perché all e figli da sfamare
a parte questo capisco che devo fare la
differenza
due progetti quindi uno sociale ovvero
produzione di sedico protesi sbaglio di
ausili
per la persona progetto ebola un
progetto internazionale prima si
chiamava robot end e da lì con le
stampanti una cosa che si stampa sovente
sono le la robotica o che sia rover
quindi quelli che camminano oppure che
sono droni entro in questo meraviglioso
mondo ovvero la possibilità di
utilizzare qualcosa che mi faccia vedere
che vi faccia raggiungere posti che per
un uomo è praticamente impossibile
il mondo dei droni mondo aiuti rotori
delle alle fisse degli alianti degli
elicotteri qualsiasi cosa quindi la
possibilità di staccarmi da terra e
avere una visione diversa mi accorgo
però che c'è uno stato dell'arte come
diceva prima andrea uno stato dell'arte
negativo c'è tutto quello che abbiamo
soli multitronic e chiamano in questo
modo in realtà con droni per rendere
solo una fetta di mercato è legato alla
ricerca militare impossibile che lo
stato dell'arte sia solo una cosa per
uccidere allora iniziò a fare ricerca
che comunque perché volevo altri stimoli
per continuare a fare produzione in sede
e scopro che ci sono altri maker che
ogni giorno ingenti ricerca incubatori
il cloud funding prodotti finiti
work in progress fanno cose bellissime
con in ultimo tori con i droni ad
esempio auto copter una persona che non
riesce neanche a camminare riesce a
guardare dall'alto il mondo pilotando un
drone con la bocca oppure gente che
investe nel nei trasporti
amazon dhl o altri ci sono anche delle
delle realtà magari più piccole in
italia che già fanno consegne si beccano
le multe da parte dell'enac ma fanno
consegna con con i droni dalla piadina
al al gelato sulla spiaggia ci sono
start up che fanno droni che seguono la
persona in volo quasi autonomo comunque
automatico la seguono dove si utilizza
in archeologia di prevenzione si
utilizza in topografia
questa sembra una foto ma è una
fotografia
via quindi tante foto esce fuori il
modello in 3d vengono utilizzate per il
controllo del territorio tramite
termocamere tramite delle fotocamere che
hanno possibilità di vedere determinati
spettri di luce questo l'immagine fatta
dal drone subito dopo il terremoto in
nepal quindi una cosa abbastanza recente
vengono utilizzati dalla polizia in
tutto il mondo anche quella italiana per
fare investigazioni ispezioni la parte
nobile vengono utilizzati per salvare le
persone quindi come ci sono i raptor che
portano alla morte ci sono
defibrillatori fatti ed air one
questo volano in maniera automatica
ci sono dei droni che portano il
salvagente direttamente sul target
quindi sulla persona che sta affogando
riducendo di un terzo la velocità di
soccorso e quel terzo salvate davvero la
vita fa la differenza sono domani che
portano medicinali salvavita
immaginate in un posto desertico e posso
certo portare una
l'insulina per un diabetico comunque
usare un farmaco come l'anti vipera
qualsiasi altro tipo di siero
questo è lo stato dell'arte purtroppo
militare è un demone che ho in ocula
sostanze oppure preleva dna e del grande
davvero in quel modo
questo invece è lo stato dell'arte e
volo si chiama è un progetto qui è fatto
molto a fumetto è un progetto tedesco in
porta due persone in maniera automatica
l'ospedale più vicino come immagino la
mia vita in realtà con imagina vita di
tutti quanti noi ormai è una tecnologia
alla portata di tutti
andate al supermercato nei cenni nella
di dio e trovate già il dolore alcuni
stanno organizzando dei corsi su cosa
puoi fare col drone rispetto alla
normativa
io immagino me perché ho due bimbe una
mediazione si appresta alla
all'adolescenza che segue
mia figlia col drone è mia figlia che
crescenzia maker adotterà qualche
marchingegno per non farsi seguire dal
drone ma immagino voi che guardate il
vicino che gli passa solo per pure che
andate a registrare la partita di calcio
di vostro figlio che volete registrare
un momento su una spiaggia oppure volete
guardare se sul tetto
la canna fumaria e occlusa o meno gli
utilizzi sono tantissimi di sicuro li
avremo sulla testa
si parla di un milione di droni tra
qualche anno sono tanti e bello gestirlo
questo tipo di di evento e io mi
immagino già nel prontuario questo noi
one pig fell mi sono tagliato un dito
durante un volo in una sala simica
estate attendere
immagino prontuario medico che ci sarà
ferita da elica bruciatura da batteria
esplosa perché comunque stanno invadendo
il nostro cielo
e allora mi viene sempre in mente quello
che diceva leonardo impegno ma vuole
volare è una volta che prova il volo
guarderà sempre il super che li che
vuole tornare e quindi io che come me
abbiate la sindrome di peter pan
alla fine io per lavoro gioco ok dei
gelidi analisti o altro comunque giocare
volando e diverso adesso vi faccio dare
pure perché
grazie mille